foreign
it's a big booming growth sector and
it's another key issue in this
desperately tight election battle
private gun ownership has rocketed under
Brazil's right-wing president chair
bolsonaro
he and his supporters contest that
bearing arms is a fundamental right
although unlike the United States this
isn't actually mentioned in Brazil's
Constitution
thank you
the day out at the assault shooting
range is something of a family affair
and all the generations take part
this is my first experience like with a
fire gun
and I think it's so cool I'm very happy
the assault club's owner has no doubts
that anything but a bolsonaro win will
be bad for him is
[Music]
there is a fear in Brazil that bolsonaro
supporting groups will fashion
themselves on America's Trump supporting
gun carriers
that fear highlighted by the closeness
of the election and the threat of
electoral linked violence
before President boltonaro Brazil was
not a country Awash with legally held
weapons but things have certainly
changed and in fact as part of his
election campaign he's actually said to
his supporters he should take up arms to
avoid inflation he's yet another
controversial issue of the many in this
election
a new group of would-be gun owners
attend their first class
they're taught through the handling and
firing of weapons
it's estimated that this year a thousand
people signed up to qualify for permits
every single day
president bolsonaro has used executive
powers to relax the country's previously
stringent gun laws imposed by his
electoral adversary Lula de Silva
with it a multi-million pound business
has thrived
this gun shop clears 1.7 million pounds
each month
the Shop's owner showed bolsonaro
supporting Senator George a sief and me
a weapon that he has imported from his
Factory in Israel would you like one
sure
for example
Senator Thief says that if bolsonaro
wins they will change the gun laws
forever yeah
and his supporters say that having more
guns in a country that already has a
terrible record for crime is at best
Reckless
the bolsonaro followers disagree arguing
that guns allow people to protect
themselves
like so many things in this election
they will never agree
still Ramsey Sky News Sao Paulo